Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
A very important message from our
prophet Sam
a statement of his that I think most of
us have heard
but
this evening we'd to try to see
this statement from a different angle,
kind of hold it under a different light
and see if we can almost in that sense
see it for the first time.
And
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam told
his companions
[Silence]
In this narration, our prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam tells us.
He says
means to try our best to perfect
everything that we can
as closely to the way that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam did it.
that anything that we are commanded by
Allah, anything that we are encouraged
to do by Allah in any of our worship of
Allah, then that we are to try our
hardest, our best
to do it as perfectly and as correctly
as possible.
He says,
now the second part is that we are to do
these things as frequently as we
possibly can. So here we have two
things.
Imagine for a moment and these words
that the prophet is using in this
particular narration saiam
they are terms used by archers.
you know, every field, every sport,
every trade, every field, if you
will, they have their own way of
speaking, right? They have their own
terminologies.
So, in the medical field, they have a
certain terminology. In in military
circles, they have a certain
terminology. In architect circles, they
have a certain terminology. And when you
use these kinds of words,
right, for instance, if I use the
word cardiac,
what is cardiac? What what field does
that kind of wording come from?
Medical field, right? Do I say I feel
cardiac good today? Is that something
that is that how we speak? Right? That's
not how we talk. Cardiac is something
that is almost specific to the medical
field. Right? These words that he's
using,
they are used in the field of archery.
That's how they used to speak when they
would train and practice and when
they would step onto the training field
or the battlefield. These words they
bring to mind archery.
Now when we speak about
which is a huge
a huge blessing from Allah. The prophet
sallall.aii
said,"
[Silence]
he said, "Whoever learns to shoot,
whoever learns to , you know, archery
and then leaves it to fall into, you
know, a lack of training, just never
picks it up again and this is a huge
blessing from Allah that he has been
ungrateful to Allah for that he has
proved ungrateful for.
So
when we use these terms
they are terms that are most usually
bring to mind archery.
Now, in archery,
in shooting in general, as human beings
fight with one another with projectiles,
there are two main things.
Number one, accuracy. Number two, volume
of fire.
I want to put as many projectiles down
range as accurately as possible, as much
as possible.
And so he uses these two terms,
meaning do everything in your pursuit of
paradise as accurately and as frequently
as you can, just an archer needs to
be accurate and he needs to be quick. He
needs to have hands of lightning, but
not too fast. Not so fast that you're
shooting willy-nilly. No,
only go as fast as you can be. What?
Accurate.
These are the terms our prophet is using
in this narration.
So he is telling us to be as accurate.
Accuracy here means what? In accordance
with what Allah has commanded. emulating
the prophet as much as we can to do
everything that we do as accurately as
possible. Number two,
which is volume as much as possible, as
frequently as possible. And this is one
of the terms that the prophet uses,
which is rebot.
Rebel
is one of those terms that can be used
for different things. Usually a rebat
means jihad but also a comes from
when you tie things together. And so he
is saying
in the statement of Allah in verse
number 200 of Alan
means
jihad and it means to do good deeds no
matter how small they are as frequently
as possible almost as if the one is tied
to the tail of the next to where they do
not cease. They do not stop for a
moment.
Then he said,
so he says,
so accuracy and volume. Then he says,
"And have in your heart the
become
elated,
become overjoyed
with expectance of good news from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Expect nothing but
good from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala as a
result of that hard work."
So here we have what? One of our two
wings. One wing is hope. Have to have
hope.
But if we have only hope, what happens?
We don't have fear. But if we have too
much fear, what happens then?
We fall into
despair.
So Allah teaches us in the Quran
that we can only fly, we can only arrive
to Allah just a a bird can only fly
with both both its wings.
Hope and fear. What does Allah always
tell us
that paradise is prepared for? He says,
he says
all through the Quran,
those who believe work righteous deeds.
Those who believe in Allah and the last
day when I say the word Allah, what's
the first attribute of Allah that comes
to mind?
well, you know, of his dealings with
his creation, what's the first thing
that comes to mind? Mercy. Allah, mercy.
And when I say the day of judgment,
what's the first thing that comes to
mind?
Fear, right? Damnation. Being held
accountable. We have hope and fear. We
have to have those two.
He says, "And expect only good from
Allah, but know and be sure that none of
you will enter paradise based solely on
his actions."
In another wording of this same
narration, he said, "And be certain that
your actions alone will not admit you
into paradise."
They won't.
So of course the question is not even
you oh messenger of Allah.
Even you haven't earned paradise.
Even you haven't earned paradise from
your own sweat.
I earned it. I earned it. Just when
I go to work and I work a full day's
work and I do my job. I have earned my
pay. Right? Is that our agreement with
Allah? I earn paradise from Allah. I
earn it. Give me what's mine.
I can speak that to my employer,
right? If I've done the work, I can say,
"Give me what's mine, and you're not
doing me a favor by paying me. This is
what belongs to me." Is that our
agreement with Allah? Pay me what's
mine. You didn't do me any favors. I did
this on my own. Is that how it works?
No,
not even you, oh messenger of Allah. How
many children did the prophet have?
Sallallah.aii wasallam.
Come.
Someone said five. Someone said six.
Seven.
Any more?
Huh?
tells us in his book
he had eight children. You know how many
of them died in his lifetime?
Seven.
And you know what? The last one, the
last child to die
was which of his children? Fatima. who
was also the first to what
to die right after he died. As a matter
of fact, she died six months after his
death. She died so soon after him that
he was told of her death before he died.
Why is that important for him to know?
So that he can
so that he can be rewarded for being
patient for her future death. Just like
Ibraim when he went to butcher is why
did he tell him?
Think about it. Why did he tell him?
Why? His son was a child. Was he old
enough to be held accountable?
No.
Right. Just barely.
So why did he wait?
Why did he tell?
Why? Why didn't he just take him and do
it? Isn't that more merciful?
Isn't that better to just no pain? Just
no pain, my son. Right?
Because we learn to conceptualize death
through the eyes of disbelievers.
You've you have the Muslim, he's in the
hospital, he's on the machines, and they
come to you and they say, "What?"
You know, he's in pain. Put him out of
his pain. How do you know he's in pain?
And second of all, is pain something
that goes unrewarded by Allah? Is the
human being created to have fun on
earth? What's our purpose?
So we don't make decisions of life and
death based on pain or lack thereof.
That's not what drives our decision
making. And so
why did he tell us why?
Who's
him?
Yes.
So that he would be rewarded by Allah
for his patience. That's why he told his
son. And so the point here is that when
it comes to our actions, our deeds,
if any of us was to earn paradise just
by way of tragedy alone,
seven children die in your lifetime.
Not only that, but the eighth one dies
right behind you.
Look at just by tragedy alone.
His mother died while he was a kid.
His father died while he never met his
father.
His grandfather died before he was even
of age. Abu Talib died and not only died
but died a karadijah
died while he was in the thick of it and
in the most difficult and egregious time
in his life that's when she died
right Hamza died in the battle of
for something silly
something that
a few men decided they were more worried
about a sword and a shield and as a
result his uncle died, right? Just by
tragedy alone, who would have earned
paradise?
Muhammad sallallah.aii wasallam. It's a
good question. He said, "And know that
none of you will enter paradise
based solely on his actions. None of you
will earn paradise truly in the complete
sense." They said, "Not even you, oh
messenger of Allah." He said,
He said, "Not even me.
I will only be admitted into paradise
only after Allah has enveloped me in his
mercy and grace."
So if we understand that
what is keeping us back from receiving
that
highness from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
because a lot of us we shoot ourselves
in the foot. We sabotage ourselves out
the gates. You know what we say to
ourselves? We have a whisper in the back
of our mind telling us, "Oh, you're not
one of them. You'll be you'll be lucky
if you get into paradise on your hands
and knees. Just, you know, you might as
well just enjoy, didn't you? Because,
you know, the hereafter, you have no
chance. You just have no chance. Just,
you know, how many of us here are
certain in your heart's heart. You don't
have to tell me. in your heart's heart.
If you really sit down and think and
really allow yourself to be honest, how
many of us truly believe that we are
going to hell for sure?
A lot of us
a lot of us feel we don't we don't
deserve paradise. But see, that's the
trick there, isn't it? Who of us
deserves paradise? Tell me one human in
history that deserves paradise,
that has earned it. I get to paradise. I
don't need any favors from anyone. I
earned it. Who is this?
None of us earn paradise.
So, we sabotage ourselves. Shaitan
whispers, "You're not good enough.
You're not one of them. you'll be all
the way in the back and you're
definitely going to get punished.
There's no way for you to get away. So,
you might as well just, you know, focus
on your dunya and, you know, let's just
get it over with. Who's to say?
Just a shaitan whispers that the
day you die is the worst day, why isn't
it the best day?
What's stopping it from being the best
day of your existence since you came to
and obtained consciousness? What is to
say that that will not be your finest
hour?
Do we enter paradise by our own deeds?
We enter paradise by Allah's what? By
Allah's grace. So why are you saying
Allah will not give you that grace? He
will not give me that grace. Okay?
Because the prophet tells us that Allah
said,
"I am what my servant thinks of me." If
he thinks good and expects good, then
that is for him. And if he thinks bad
and expects bad, then that's for him. So
you limit yourself. That's not for me.
As if you are the one who is going to
earn paradise. You're not. You are a
recipient of Allah's grace. Do not shut
that off and deprive yourself of Allah's
grace. Rather, your attitude is
the attitude of the prophets is, "Oh
Allah, I need anything that you have for
me."
And you expect a lot. You expect a lot
from Allah. You expect everything from
Allah. Everything. But it's not because
of you. You didn't earn it. You're
expecting it because that is who Allah
is. And you're hoping to be one of those
people. Why can't it be you? Why not?
Why not? Why can't one of us be of the
best of all of humankind today here from
now in this entire generation? Maybe one
of us, two of us, all of us is the best
people in the entire world. Why is that
not possible?
So, we sabotage ourselves. And we'll end
with this. When it comes to self-
sabotage, you remember the story of
Misam with
you know told him don't ask me about
anything
and so
he asked the first time and then the
second time he asked and what did he say
when told him the second time
paraphrase
[Arabic recitation]
Did Al tell him that? Who put that on
himself? MS put it on himself. He's the
one that did that. Why not? Just I'll
keep making mistakes, but I'll learn
eventually. Please be patient with me.
Couldn't it have been that? No. But he
said, "If I ask you again,
okay, shake on it. That's your rules.
You made those rules for yourself."
Didn't place those rules on him. He made
that rule on himself. And so when he
failed what he agreed to, what happened?
He was deprived to the point that
Muhammad sallallah.aii wasallam said,
"If only MS would have been a little bit
more patient, we could have learned
more." That narration is in Bkari.
And so we don't limit ourselves. We are
the ones that limit ourselves. The
Shaitan cannot limit you. He can only
convince you to limit yourself. And this
whole shenanigans about believe in
yourself with
tell me one time when
is that is that a part of wisdom? Have
have believe in yourself. Is that wise?
Most of us live our lives that. It
sounds so poetic. Yes. Yes. Believe in
myself. Tell me where is that in the
Quran. We don't have that in the Quran.
We don't have that in the Sunnah.
Believe in yourself. You know we have in
the Sunnah.
Don't ever place me in charge of my own
affairs for the blink of an eye. Always
keep me in your grasp and in your
protection. We don't believe in
ourselves.
We believe in who? Allah. When we
repent, who are we relying on to carry
us through that repentance?
Allah. You know why most repentance
fails? Because we believe in ourselves.
We expect that we're going to do it.
Where are you going to do it?
Where are you going to save yourself?
Oh, human being, how can you save
yourself? You don't even know what's
around the corner. It's only Allah can
save you. That is when a person repents,
they believe in themselves, they fall on
their face every single time. Every
time. And that's a blessing from Allah
because if they don't, they'll become
arrogant. They'll think that they earned
paradise. And that's even worse.
Instead,
a person believes in Allah, doesn't
believe in himself. What happens? He is
carried through. But we are afraid. We
are afraid that if I let myself go into
Allah's grace that he's going to let me
down.
That's what we are afraid of. And that's
where the rubber meets the road. That is
why our the companions of our prophet
were so great because they never allowed
themselves to give in to those fears.
[Arabic recitation]